Họng tâm dựng người tháng 7 năm 2018, giờ điều phương khi đại tái vàn vô nức buồn dịch
bữa giờ khỏi con hộ của mình tại Quận Holosyski, một khu sân kêu năm ở phía Nam
Tụ đầu kế và đang đi bộ băng qua đường.
Một người dan ông tiếp cận từ phía sau, mất người nãy yêu phát đạn ở cửa liên gần
bằng số 3 tháng, khiến ông vô nức từ văng tại chỗ.
Đại tái vàn vô nức là một sĩ quán kỳ cử giữ vì chi chính phòng một thuộc mùi sau của các quan ăning
của Kênh A, S-B-U, chung chắc khách chiến dịch đặc biệt trong khủng bố vào vị Anh in Cuc Sa.
S-B-U và kể ra Cuc Sa của Kênh A đang phối hợp điều tra vụ việc, cho biết đang thực hiện các vị pháp
cần thiết để sắp mình tính tích và truyết bắt hủ tụ.
Cơ quan điều tra cũng đang xem xếc của Anh theo hưởng ông Miu sát hại một sĩ quán lực lượng bú tra học ke quan ăning.